theresa alerte lancée aujourd'hui par la
défenseure des droits des droits sur la
gestion des foules protestataires en
france pour claire et dont un face à
face tendu s'est installée ces dernières
années entre les policiers et les
manifestants un rapport publié alors que
la nouvelle doctrine du maintien de
l'ordre doit être présenté sous peu des
explications de katia technique
clairet dont la nouvelle défenseur des
droits livre ce lundi 29 novembre une
étude sur la philosophie du maintien de
l'ordre en france en particulier dans sa
dimension confrontation elle son titre d
escalade de la violence et gestion des
foules protestataires l'étude a été
menée en interrogeant gendarmerie et
police and an après le début des gilet
jaune a noté la préfecture de police de
paris n'a pas voulu participer à cette
étude elle rappelle qu'après les
manifestations de mai 68 une relative
pacification du maintien de l'ordre en
france s'étaient développées mais depuis
quelques années il en va tout autrement
les chercheurs de l'étude soulignent le
tour pris par le traitement médiatique
des manifestations les manifestants se
plaignent de tactique de maintien de
l'ordre et de l' usage de la force
tandis que les forces de sécurité
cherche à légitimer leur action et
s'agace de la multiplication des
observateurs de manifestations ou de
journalistes citoyens ou non le tout
dans une logique de face à face il note
aussi un tournant la judiciarisation des
manifestations les interpellations il
remarque également que le recours aux
forces locales de sécurité
habitué aux interpellations individuel
et en suffisamment formés aux situations
de maintien de l'ordre peuvent aboutir à
une inadéquation se traduisant souvent
par la mise en danger des manifestants
et c'est cette logique de confrontation
parfois violente qui est interrogé par
cette étude la défenseure des droits en
veut pour preuve les exercices
d'entraînement des forces de sécurité
dans des villes artificielles en france
elle met directement en scène des
situations de danger et d' escalade
exagérées note le rapport tandis qu'en
allemagne eh bien il ya également des
simulations de manifestations violentes
mais aussi de rassemblement calme où se
développe l'art du dialogue
de la désescalade car nos voisins
européens ont eux tenté de réfléchir à
la pacification du maintien de l'ordre
en 2010 la police suédoise a lancé un
projet européen go diack auquel ont
participé dix pays comme le royaume-uni
l'espagne le portugal
l'objectif rétablir le dialogue la
communication lors des manifestations
les français nous ont malheureusement
pas assisté le projet met l'accent sur
l'adaptation de l'action policière au
public manifestants ils doivent
faciliter leur expression communiquer
avec les membres de la foule et ne
réprime et que les éléments violents
bien entendu il ne s'agit que de
principe sur le papier parfois
difficiles à adapter sur le terrain mais
la nasse les lacrymogènes et autres l bd
ne sont pas des figures imposées
particulièrement dans le nord de
l'europe et l'étude note que la belgique
tente d'adopter ce schéma de désescalade
en privilégiant le dialogue la
concertation la responsabilisation la
coordination et la gestion de crise le
maintien de l'ordre est ramené à sa
mission de prévention et
d'accompagnement des manifestations avec
un objectif le rapprochement dans les
relations entre la police et la
population
le schéma national du maintien de
l'ordre proposé en france à l'automne
2020 ensuite amendé sera bientôt
représenter mais la défenseure des
droits note qu'il reste dans la logique
de confrontation avec une gestion très
réactive voire brutale des événements
que l'on tient pour susceptibles
d'engendrer des désordres je cite le
contraste avec les leçons que les pays
du réseau go diack ou la belgique ont
tiré des épisodes altermondialistes du
début des années 2000 reste notable
conclut l'étude le troisième
anniversaire des gilet jaune est aussi
l'occasion de montrer à quel point cette
logique de confrontation a occasionné
des dégâts durables tant physiques que
symbolique